yeah that was one of the great things
that in watching one of Jay schaeffer's
videos he said in going small your world
actually expands because then you're
freed up in terms of time spent caring
for the home and also money can you talk
about have you had any sort of
epiphanies in that area or has your life
sort of freed up in some sense because
you know I know you're you're busy doing
a documentary and you were making so
maybe now is it's premature to ask that
but at some point you feel like your
world will definitely change because you
won't have this huge liability on your
back well I mean I feel like you know
one thing with our story which is you
know becoming more part of the film as
well as that you know I think that we're
still figuring out you know how the tiny
house fits into our lives and it's great
that it's it's given us the flexibility
you know too I mean I'm from the east
coast and I've been thinking about going
back to the east coast to be closer to
family and things like that and so it's
given us the flexibility to you know if
i were to to rent a small apartment you
know on the east coast and then we can
also have the tiny house in Colorado
that is a base to come back to in
Colorado that's a place that we own you
know we're not paying rent for and I
think it's given us more flexibility you
know to kind of explore options and and
live in different places and have the
kind of life that we want to live and
there's definitely a more of a sense of
security when you have owned a house and
anything able to use a homeowner
probably experiences this when they when
they buy it where you know you
especially when you own it outright and
you don't owe the bank anything for it
but it's it's like always a place that
you can come back to and so there's a
sense like oh if if nothing else if I
lose my job or whatever at least you
know there's this place than I can go
stay that I belong in so there's the
sort of man security that comes with
that and you know it's already kinda
opens doors in a way but as far as the J
shave a quote I think that also is sort
of alluding to the this the sense that
when you live in in the sort of smaller
place and that takes less time to end a
energy and emotion to think about that
you have all that extra energy too
emotional to like sort of build your
community or be out in the world
and I think that you know that's
definitely the case and even in building
the house you know we have a lot of our
friends come and help out and then have
comes you know and stayed up on the land
with us and stuff and it's been great it
already a building community but you
know when we're up there too we you know
you're inside but it's this it's it's
it's nice because the whole world really
does kind of open up to you and it's
it's kind of like building a home that
almost feels more in the larger world in
ways that a larger house doesn't feel
yes I think also from a purely design
perspective I mean just like the window
to wall ratio is so much greater in a
tiny house that even though you're
inside of a house I mean you have all of
these windows so just the presence of
the natural world or the neighborhood or
wherever you happen to be is so much
more a reality
you